we got the the best job in town i think
the best job in town but
there are a lot of good ones so today is
one of those good news days for you
we've got gorgeous clear skies out there
the winds have calmed down
but it is pretty chilly so i advise
don't leave home without a nice warm
coat or jacket it's 36 degrees right now
we've got some 30s and a mix of some low
40s around town we're 10 degrees cooler
than we were yesterday sunrise we're
getting closer to it at 6 38
sunset at 5 12. days are definitely
getting longer
i know that you notice that they're
getting longer this should be friday
sorry about that 66 today our normal
high is 61.
so no record highs but definitely above
normal we have a super weekend that's
coming
look at saturday mid 60's super bowl
sunday 68 degrees
man just a stellar weekend as we look
over the west the reason for all that
good sunshine and above normal
temperatures
is this nice ridge of high pressure
building over the west
so there's rain and snow in the midwest
the mid-south
and even across the northeast where they
had that big nor'easter
polar plunge is bringing really cold air
into the midwest
as well as the northern plains through
the weekend the southeast getting a fair
dose of rain this morning and a chance
of thunderstorms
all the way down into tampa today and
tomorrow
even sunday morning super bowl morning
they'll be looking for
thunderstorms but the afternoon looks
like they'll have more sunshine highs
in the low 70s so game time looks pretty
good for sunday
48 degrees for a mountain today pretty
breezy winds we're looking at northwest
winds
could be 30 35 miles an hour at pit
mount charleston if you want to go up
and the weekend again lots of sunshine
next week we get clouds monday
tuesday then back to mostly sunny
wednesday thursday look at all those
60's